let's talk about democratic socialism  not communism mr. Bloomberg that's a  cheap shot let's talk about democratic  let's talk about what goes on in  countries like Denmark with Pete  correctly pointed out they have a much  higher quality of life in many respects  then we'd what are we talking about we  are living in many ways in a socialist  society right now problem is as dr.  Martin Luther King reminded us we have  socialism for the very rich  rugged individualism for the poor  greatest Donald's let me finish when  Donald Trump gets eight hundred million  dollars in tax breaks and subsidies to  be linked to build luxury condominiums  that's socialism for the rich Great Wall  thought we have to subsidize Walmart's  workers who are on Medicaid and food  stamps because the wealthiest family in  America pay starvation wages that  socialism for the rich this I believe in  democratic socialism for working people  not billionaires health care for all  educational opportunity  you